- I'm going to come to, you guys first.
What d'you wanna hear a rap about?
- [Audience] The queen.
- The queen.
Do you want to pick a
specific aspect of the queen?
Make it more like, more challenging.
- [Audience] Her looks.
- Her looks, the Queen's looks.
Oh yeah baby, that 94 year old hottie.
You guys over here.
We got the Queen's looks.
What's it going to be?
- [Audience] Labor day.
- Labor day? Amazing.
What a great strategy to give
to the British guy a holiday
that he's not even sure what it's about.
(audience laughing)
Everyone gets pregnant and gives birth?
I don't know.
(audience laughing)
Labor day, the Queens looks.
Front row.
- [Audience] Hacking.
- What?
- Hacking? Amazing.
As in like, *blurble noises*? Yeah cool.
Hey look, I've only seen the Matrix.
That's what I think hacking
is: *blurble noises*
Cool, that looks like someone
just going down on someone very badly.
(audience laughing)
Deleted scene from the matrix.
So hacking, Labor Day, the Queen's looks.
What?
- [Audience] Football.
- Football wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait.
So football is said all the time,
but then you specified that.
What type?
- [Audience] SEC football.
- SCC football?
SEC. Now what is that?
(people chattering)
The South Eastern Conference football.
I'm excited for that bit because wow.
Apparently, oh you're going to hate
when I try to rap about it.
I know nothing.
Let's get one final one
from you guys over here.
Oh! Fucking hell!
If you didn't hear what
he said, he said Epstein.
Cause...you piece of shit.
Right, the rule is I can't
turn down suggestions, so okay.
So we have SEC football, Epstein.
I'm presuming Jeffrey, right?
Yeah. Cool.
Okay. Jeffrey Epstein, the Queen's looks,
Labor Day and hacking.
This then, lovely people
at the Comedy Cellar,
a little treat for y'all.
A freestyle rap.
That's a rap made up on the spot,
based entirely on those suggestions.
None of it has been performed before.
None of it is written.
It will never be performed again.
Do not worry yourselves.
It won't be anywhere near as
atrociously embarrassingly bad
as you are expecting a 29 year old,
privately educated, middle
class, British white boy to be.
(audience cheering)
Yeah, that's what I like.
Let's drop that beat.
Lets do it.
I'm so excited.
You're so skeptical
about this, aren't you?
Just looking over there,
but he's got no idea.
Down a bit.
♪ Guy in the front row
looking right at me ♪
♪ Saying how's this white
bro rapping bout SEC ♪
♪ Gonna make the words rhyme ♪
♪ Gonna make it make sense ♪
♪ Yeah, talk about football
Southeast Conference ♪
♪ Better than the North West ♪
♪ Better than the West East ♪
♪ When I see the football players ♪
♪ Play a visual feast for the eyes ♪
♪ They got meaty thighs ♪
♪ I want to get their ball ♪
♪ Oval shaped my surprise ♪
♪ I kick a field goal ♪
♪ How many points is it? ♪
♪ I don't know nothing
about just don't quiz it ♪
♪ I don't even know
why they switch teams ♪
♪ I'm hung up on shit
like Jeffrey Epstein ♪
♪ Out there in a cell on suicide watch ♪
♪ Conspiracy theorist, they
be like they scotched ♪
♪ All the ideals, assassins lining up ♪
♪ Trying to get him when he's
in there right locked up ♪
♪ Like knock, knock, Jeffrey,
me with a rope again ♪
♪ Too many underage hymens were broken ♪
♪ You've gotta punish,
die for your crimes ♪
♪ Put it round your neck
like several times ♪
♪ Yeah asphixy-wank, like
he was choking on limes ♪
♪ Sorry let me move on
no choking on lines ♪
♪ Got no knowledge ♪
♪ I'm here to say I wear white ♪
♪ Why? Because labor day ♪
♪ That's the only thing I know about it ♪
♪ Got no other fact ♪
♪ Looking at my calendar
I'm like I must relax ♪
♪ I've got to look it
up on Wikipedia after ♪
♪ Is this Saturday or Sunday? ♪
♪ That's a disaster ♪
♪ Monday probably ♪
♪ I give a wide berth ♪
♪ I should have saved the pun
about women giving birth ♪
♪ It would have been better
if I put it right there ♪
♪ I'm attacking anybody
in an office with care ♪
♪ I see a guy wearing a
hoodie and glasses there ♪
♪ Got a MacBook Pro ♪
♪ He's not aware that
I'm spying on him yeah ♪
♪ His skills lacking ♪
♪ No surveillance when
I watch him hacking ♪
♪ Oh I'm amazing ♪
♪ Yes, I'm on Amazon ♪
♪ I'm going to get all the
credit cards, I'll hammer some ♪
♪ Here is a worm, a Trojan virus ♪
♪ I know nothing about
computers, just silence ♪
♪ Are you a hacker bro with the binary ♪
♪ Probably maybe but in China they see ♪
♪ all the secrets ♪
♪ They hacking nationally actually ♪
♪ What was the last one we needed to do? ♪
♪ It's in my dream ♪
♪ It's wet when I wake
cause I dream of the Queen ♪
♪ I see her ♪
♪ Oh yeah I wanna be in her ♪
♪ I don't mind that she's a wrinkler ♪
♪ She's got little
corgis, got little dogs ♪
♪ I wanna introduce her to my big log. ♪
♪ That's disgusting ♪
♪ Why would I say that? ♪
♪ It's treasonous ♪
♪ Yeah, that is a fact ♪
♪ I would find Prince Philip ♪
♪ He's a 95 year old dude ♪
♪ I'm going to get a cliff ♪
♪ Push him off, move out of the way ♪
♪ There's a new King in town ♪
♪ And then like that
hacking on the queen. ♪
♪ I'd go down ♪
(audience cheering)